biographer and historian Edward Rena Han
is author of the Kennedys at war it
presents an account of the Kennedy
family in the years leading up to and
during World War two
beginning with Joseph Kennedy stint as
ambassador to Great Britain this public
lives discussion is just under an hour
good evening and welcome to the
Cambridge Public Library my name is Gale
Pettiford Willett I'm program
coordinator for the Cambridge Public
Library and I'd like to welcome you to
our series books on Broadway the
Cambridge Public Library author series
before I introduced our author for this
evening Edward J Wren ahem I'd like to
make a few announcements about things
that will be happening at the library in
the next few weeks tomorrow evening
continuing in our beyond rhetoric and
retaliation program dispatches from a
wounded world there will be discussion
of human aspects global politics and
domestic Eve events and that will be
happening at 6:30 and on may 22nd
Julia glass first time author will be
talking about her new book the three
June's
so please join us if you're not a part
of our mailing list and want to make
sure that you're here at all our events
at the library you can do that by
signing up at the back table and on your
way out please take the Flyers that are
available for you elder J Ranahan is the
author of the new book the Kennedys at
war 1937 to 1945 in my research
regarding mr. rena hen he is described
as an extra ordinarily diverse writer
and complex man for twenty years he was
a computer editor and offered six
computer technology books in the 1970s
he played music he played guitar and
he's saying with his friend Pete Seeger
Ranahan is a fifth generation New Yorker
married with two children but now lives
in New York I'm sorry in Rhode Island he
is the author of the Lions pride the
secret six and John Burroughs
somebody once asked John F Kennedy how
he became a war hero it was easy he
replied they sank my boat
JFK's adventure aboard pt-109 in the
Second World War is fairly well-known
Kennedy's boat did indeed sink in the
Pacific but it was his able leadership
that helped his men survive in dangerous
waters and then on a deserted island
this episode compromises only a sliver
of Edward J run hence J our story of the
Kennedy family at war Rena hen argues
quite convincingly that the war was a
transformative experience of young JFK's
life and set the tone for both the
triumphs and tragedies that would mark
the family for the rest of the century
once when asked about his writing the
author said I am fascinated by the
process of biography and historical
narrative throughout my schooling my two
great loves were always the subjects of
history and composition merging these
two things I find my voice as an author
the past and of particular importance to
me
the American past is full of wonderful
untold stories that lay waiting down at
the far ends of neglected corridors of
memory ready to enlighten us on the
sources of the political and social
Malil of our day please help me in
welcoming Edward J Rena hen
thank you very much Gail thank you for
that introduction and all that research
boy my safe my safely buried past has
come back don't worry I'm not gonna sing
as Gail mentioned one of my previous
books published four years ago in 1998
is a book called the lion's pride and
that is a book that studied Theodore
Roosevelt and his four sons during the
period of World War one and in
researching that book I became very
intrigued by and engaged with the idea
of the the psychology the emotions the
motivations of privileged young people
during time of war and I also became
very interested in the idea of the
democratizing aspect of military service
once the lion's pride had been published
and I was done with that I was looking
for another place to bring this line of
inquiry this angle of vision and it
seemed sensible to take it to another
notable American political family and to
another war thus the Kennedy is at war
now the the Kennedy is in the Roosevelts
are of course very different families
but there there are some similarities
both families had Airmen who died in
battle both families had Harvard
connections both families were quite
affluent although the Kennedy family
wealth certainly dwarfed the Roosevelt
family wealth and both families had some
tradition of public service now the the
differences between the families are of
course quite severe aside from the
differences in pedigree there's also the
differences in the father's that we're
dealing with in these two families
Theodore Roosevelt
of course was a warrior the hero of San
Juan Hill he was a New York
Knickerbocker who had nothing to prove
socially and he was a man who was really
imbued with the idea of public service
Joseph P Kennedy on the other hand was
something of a social climber he was a
religious and ethnic outsider who wanted
to be in the American social hierarchy
in the worst way and wasn't he was also
a fairly ruthless businessman who always
focused first above all things on
maximizing his wealth and his family's
place in the world
unlike Theodore Roosevelt the warrior
Joseph P Kennedy was a World War 1 draft
dodger who once called soldiering quote
a sucker's game and discouraged his two
eldest fighting aged sons Joe Kennedy
jr. and Jack from going to the front
lastly Joe Kennedy was a sometime public
servant who pursued public service for
the most part as a tool for gaining
social and political prominence of the
type Theodore Roosevelt and Theodore
Roosevelt's cousin Franklin for that
matter had been born to he was Joseph
Kennedy the consummate fixer there was
an old story about Joseph Kennedy jr. as
a teenager when he lost a very important
sailboat race Joseph Kennedy senior
greeted the failure with a huge outburst
ranting about how there was no room for
losers and the Kennedy family a few days
later as if to make up for his outburst
Kennedy senior bought jr. a new main
song and jr. promptly started winning
again it was only several months later
that jr. realized that his new main soul
ran nine inches too high along the mast
giving him more sail than the people he
was compete
against and and thus an unfair advantage
this episode foreshadowed much of what
was to come
Joe senior would always do whatever it
took to improve his children's odds
lengthening their sails in many
different ways throughout their lives
only with the world war would he bump up
against a contest he could not fix to
the certain advantage of his offspring
now in the context of World War two and
the Kennedys it's important to remember
that Joe Kennedy rather admired certain
aspects of fascism he thought it a
rather efficient political engine he
also did not think that war against the
Axis powers would be a winnable or be
necessary and he did everything in his
power during his time as ambassador to
the court of st. James to foster Neville
Chamberlain's policies of appeasement
these actions included unauthorized
contacts with Herbert von Dirk's and
Nazi ambassador to the court of st.
James who cabled home at one point that
Kennedy was quote Germany's best friend
in London in other words Joseph P
Kennedy was no Theodore Roosevelt
now TRS three sons who survived World
War one always look back on that fight
as the critical defining moment in their
lives the same can be said for the one
son of Joseph P Kennedy who fought in
World War two and lived to tell the tale
I firmly believe Jack Kennedy once wrote
that as much as I was shaped by anything
so was I shaped by the hand of fate
moving in World War two of course the
same can be said of almost any American
or British or Australian man of my
generation the war made us it was and is
our single greatest move moment the
memory of the war is a key to our
characters it serves as a break wall
between the indolence of our youth and
the earnestness of our manhoods no
school or parent
could have shaped us the way that fight
shaped us no other experience would have
brought forth in us the same fortitude
and resilience we were much shrewder and
sadder when that long battle finally
finished the war made us get serious for
the first time in our lives
we've been serious ever since and we
show no signs of stopping of course
John Kennedy's war record provided a
great political benefit every campaign
he ever ran emphasized his status as a
warrior and a hero he displayed as
Purple Heart and Navy and Marine Corps
medals prominently in each of his
several offices through the years he
kept on his desk preserved in plastic
the coconut shell on which he'd
scratched his dramatic if redundant
rescue plea after the sinking of PT 109
a float in his inaugural parade featured
a full-size replica of the vessel he'd
made famous and male visitors to the
Kennedy White House routinely received
PT boat eye pins as souvenirs
nevertheless in public jack often
appraised his war records sardonically
during his presidency very early in his
presidency after viewing the film pt-109
starring cliff robertson kennedy told a
friend that the popular account of that
event was quote more screwed up than
cuba but those who knew kennedy best
realized that the war always remained a
very important part of him Robert E
Hartman the journalist for the LA Times
who covered Kennedy extensively through
the late 50s and into the early 60s
wrote that everything that was most
important about John Kennedy dated from
the great adventure of the war Hartman
made the important point that Jack's
several days of pure survival after the
loss of pt-109 in the summer of 43 were
quote the only time Kennedy ever was
wholly on his own where the $1,000,000
his father gave him wouldn't buy one cop
of water likewise Hartman noted that
what he called Kennedy's superabundant
charm was never more engaging than when
he left back into wartime reminiscence
with a receptive veteran of the Solomon
campaign Jack once told a friend that
the war had made him at the same time
that it had savaged his family it turned
my father and my brothers and my sisters
and I upside down he wrote and sucked
all the oxygen out of our smug and
comfortable assumptions we still with
the old battles long over have great
confidence great Kennedy confidence
which is the main strength of our tribe
but we sons and daughters no longer have
that easy witless untested and
meaningless confidence on which we'd
been weaned before the war our father
had us pretty well trained to appear to
ourselves and others as unbeatable and
immortal a little bit like gods now
that's over with now after all that we
experienced and lost in the war we
finally understand that there is nothing
inevitable about us and that's a healthy
thing to know writing in 1999 Richard D
Mahoney said world war ii breached the
kennedy family and most importantly it's
patriarchy like a wrecking ball the
purpose of my new book the Kennedys at
war is to tell the story of that breach
an act of destruction that in my view
enabled the redefinition of a family and
the making of a man John F Kennedy the
book comprises many different stories
just a few of which I'll touch on here
tonight it is of course in part the tale
of Joseph P Kennedy's appeasing
political shipwreck in the late 1930s
but more importantly I think the book is
also the tale of competition between
brothers Joseph P Kennedy jr. the eldest
of Joseph Kennedy's brood was born in
19:15 Jack Kennedy the next kid in line
was arrived two years later 1917 looking
back on her two eldest sons while
writing her memoirs in the late 60s and
early 70s Rose Kennedy recalled that Jo
was not only the older of the two but
also the bigger and stronger
nevertheless she said Jack could fight
like a fury when he had to
she remembered them as children racing
round the block on their bicycles each
refusing to veer out of the way of the
other Jack went to the hospital for 28
stitches after the inevitable collision
long after both Joe and Jack were dead
Bobby Kennedy ten years younger than Joe
and eight years younger than Jack
described how as a boy he would lie in
his bed at night and quote hear the
sound of Joe banging Jack's head against
the wall commenting on his brother Joe
during an interview in in the early
years of his presidency Jack Kennedy
said Joe have a had what he called quote
a pugnacious personality later on its
moved out but it was a problem in my
boyhood of course the young jack was
easy to pick on because he was a wreck
physically Robert Kennedy was to recall
that at least one-half of the days that
Jack spent on this earth were days of
intense physical pain when we were
growing up together said Bobby we used
to laugh about the great risk the
mosquito took in biting Jack Kennedy
with some of his blood the mosquito was
almost certain to die Jack came very
near to death himself of scarlet fever
at the age of two a slight deformity of
his back required the occasional use of
crutches and a brace he also had asthma
and was extremely thin at six his mother
described as a appearance as being elfin
he received the last rites of the Roman
Catholic
when he was 14 during a potentially
fatal attack of appendicitis after which
he became so thin that his grandfather
John honey Fitz Fitzgerald one-time
congressman and mayor of Boston offered
him a dollar for every pound he gained
Jack's perennial complaints throughout
his youth included a strange mix of
flu-like symptoms chills hives fevers
abdominal pain and occasional fainting
all of these stemming from a sudden
unpredictable and unexplained drop in
his white blood cell count painful
injections of liver extracts sometimes
improved his condition whatever was
wrong with him it had the interesting
side effect of sometimes turning his
skin to a jaundice like yellow or when
he was lucky - the yellowish brown of a
healthy tan Jack's affliction would not
be correctly diagnosed until 1947 when
doctors at Boston's Lahey Clinic finally
identified their longtime patient as
suffering from Addison's disease the
steady decline of the adrenal glands and
consequent degeneration of hormonal
output without which the body is not
able to adequately combat infections and
other medical stresses Jack's illness
rose and then subsided unpredictably
throughout his life and throughout his
childhood with long hiatuses of health
in between the attacks still he spent a
lot of time in infirmaries and in
hospitals he was often confined to his
bed for weeks he maximized his time by
devouring the complete works of Burke
given Winston Churchill and other major
writers on history and politics when one
of his father's friends visited him at
the Mayo Clinic in 1934 she found Jack
lying in bed very pale reading the world
crisis by Churchill interestingly he
also read Henry Pringles life of
Theodore Roosevelt at about the same
time and one might guess took heart in
the story of the sickly young TRS rise
to robust manhood
from a plainly infirm tiled hood it was
perhaps not a coincidence that he
subsequently went west
just like TR to work on a ranch and
build his stamina returning to play
football for Choate and later for
Harvard's 1936 freshman squad taking a
cue from what he'd read of TR Jack
disdained self-pity never complained and
always performed to the maximum his
strength and talent would allow as the
head coach at Choate would recall Jack
made up for what he lacked in athletic
ability with his fight Jack's friend
from Harvard the gridiron hero Torbett
McDonald expressed a similar sentiment
when he said that guts was the word for
what Jack had plenty of guts when war
came Jack predictably failed a physical
exam for the army and then promptly did
an end-run around navy doctors using
family influence to help pave the way in
order to get his commission and get into
uniform of course he might very well
have with honor withdrawn into civilian
life clutching his army 4f
classification but he refused to do so
subsequent to getting into the service
he eventually also pulled strings though
I must emphasize no strings provided by
his father to get away from stateside
assignment and into action in the
Solomon Islands and we all know what
happened in the Solomon Islands by the
end of 1943 Jack was a famous war hero
in the wake of his adventure some would
say misadventure with pt-109 Joe jr. in
turn had tried and failed to confront
the enemy to do great things and to earn
medals of the type with which Jack
seemed to be festoon he did not fail
through any lack of courage he failed
merely through lack of viable
assignments he'd spent much of early
1943 at the Roosevelt roads Naval Air
Base San Juan flying eminently safe
patrols over the north northern Atlantic
shoreline
an assignment that he suspected had been
orchestrated by his father Joe was later
assigned to the Naval Air Station at
North walk and did not get to Europe
until September of 43 thereafter he flew
a liberator nightly patrols of the Bay
of Biscay searching for u-boats that
consistently failed to appear through
May of 1944 then he went to operation
cork another sub hunting operation
designed to clear the British channel of
the u-boats which might otherwise
disrupt the Allied Armada set to cross
to France in early June for d-day these
u-boats also stubbornly refused to
appear I now have 39 missions and will
probably have 50 by the time I leave he
wrote his parents in mid-june a week and
a half after d-day but he continued it
doesn't prove a hell of a lot he had yet
to engage the enemy he had yet to get a
medal he had yet to match the heroics of
his brother his younger brother Jack
this people who knew Joe well say was
the reason why in the summer of 1944 he
volunteered to fly a vital test flight
for project anvil the Navy's version of
the Army's aphrodite project this really
half-baked and ill-conceived program
called for b54 Liberator bombers to be
gutted and then filled from stem to
stern with torpex a highly unstable
explosive 25,000 pounds of the stuff the
plan was for a pilot and a co-pilot to
lift the heavily loaded plane off the
ground and get it up to cruising
altitude and then pass control of the
aircraft to a radio pilot than a nearby
mother ship before bailing out once the
crew was safely off the plane the b54
was to be flown across the
English Channel and directly into some
likely otherwise hard to hit target
somewhere behind German lines in France
targets such as v2 launch bunkers and
submarine pens at least that was the
plan
success would mean great honor probably
a Navy Cross and the Navy Cross is what
Joe jr. wanted desperately Joseph
Kennedy jr. died on August 12th 1944
with his co-pilot Wilfred Budd Willie
not far from the airbase in East Anglia
from which they'd taken off only minutes
before Joe and his copilot had just
thrown the switch to hand remote control
over to the mother aircraft and were
about to bail out when their plane
exploded in one enormous earth and sky
shaking blast Elliott Roosevelt the son
of the president who flew near Joe's
aircraft in a mosquito making a film of
the anvil test nearly died as well his
small plane was damaged and just barely
limped back to the airbase a twin
farthing Ferris field before the before
coming apart
both Joe jr. and Budd Willy were
instantly incinerated in the blast no
traces of their bodies were ever found
Joe received his naval Navy Cross the
following autumn posthumously shortly
after the tragedy Jack wrote to his
brother wrote of his brother he had
great physical courage and stamina a
complete confidence in himself which
never faltered and he did everything
with a great verve and gusto and though
these very qualities were in the end his
undoing yet they made his life a
wonderful one to live Joe's copilot on
his last fatal mission bud Willy was a
dirt-poor farm boy from Fort Worth Texas
I've got to tell you I find it very
interesting and ironic and touching that
on the morning of November 22nd 1963
Jack
Kennedy shared the last breakfast he
would ever eat on this earth with the
widow and three grown children of Bud
Willy they had breakfast together at the
hotel Texas and Fort Worth it is also
worth noting I think let's let's give
the man his due that Joseph P Kennedy
senior had paid for each of those three
children to go to college and had done
so without publicity in fact I think
this is the first time it's being
publicized that fact I also find it
interesting and ironic that it was
really through their wartime service
service that if their father had had his
way they would not have rendered that
Joseph Kennedy's two eldest sons created
a post-war reality in which their
father's political ambitions for the
family could at last be realized
given ambassador Kennedy's embarrassing
record of appeasement and pro-nazi
rhetoric there would not have been much
of a political future for any Kennedy
after World War two without Joe Jr's
counterbalancing martyrdom in Europe and
Jack's much publicized tour in the
Pacific now if you'll allow me I'll I'll
indulge just one more Roosevelt II and
an analogy one more quirky parallel
Quentin Roosevelt the youngest son of
Theodore Roosevelt and an aviator loved
a certain hauntingly beautiful poem that
seemed to those who loved Quentin even
more haunting after his death in France
in July of 1918 in the introduction it
was mentioned my association in previous
years with the composer and singer Pete
Seeger Pete Seeger's uncle Alan Seeger
the trench poet of World War one had a
poem that became quite famous still is
rather famous Alan Seger's rendezvous
as he called it and it's now more
popularly known as rendezvous with death
and it was a poem that was in fact
strangely prophetic from the moment
Seeger pended a Harvard man just like
Roosevelt and just like Joe jr. and Jack
Kennedy Seeger died within weeks of
writing the poem while fighting with the
French against the Germans in 1916 after
Joe Kennedy's death Jack who attended
Harvard with Pete Seeger by the way in
the same class
Jack latched on to Alan Seger's verses
memorized them and thereafter repeated
the poem often claiming it as his
favorite he even in time took the
trouble to teach it to his daughter and
there are still today a few survivors of
Camelot who remember Caroline's sitting
on her father's lap reciting Seger's
somber and fatalistic lines I have a
rendezvous with death at some disputed
barricade when spring comes back with
rustling shade and apple blossoms fill
the air I have a rendezvous with death
when spring brings back blue days and
fair it may be he shall take my hand and
lead me into his dark land and close my
eyes and quench my breath it may be I
shall pass him still I have a rendezvous
with death on some scarred slope of
battered Hill when spring comes round
again this year and the first meadow
flowers appear
God knows twere better to be deep
pillowed in silk and scented down where
love throbs out in blissful sleep pulse
night pulse and breath to breath where
hushed awakenings a deer but I've a
rendezvous with death at midnight in
some flaming town when spring trips
north again this year and I to my
pledged word am true I shall not fail
this rendezvous as we now know it's was
not only Joe Junior
that had that rendezvous but also Jack
himself and of course Bobby and their
sister Kathleen aka kik Kennedy who died
tragically in 1948 and whose own unique
story of love and faith and loss is yet
another thread in the tale I endeavor to
weave in the Kennedys at war now just to
wrap up I just like to read a couple of
pages just about three or four
paragraphs from the book that give a a
hint a taste of where Jack Kennedy was
at the end of his experience of the war
and at the beginning of his political
career and of course I was too witless
to take the book out of my bag
beforehand so I'll just grab it right
now
LEM Billings who is Jack's close friend
from Choate LEM Billings observed that
up until 1944 Jack's competition with
Joe jr. had to a considerable extent
defined his personality
indeed the brothers constant rivalry had
always seemed their main point of
contact their primary bond now with Joe
GaN the bond
nevertheless continued with the arrival
retaking on new and impossible
dimensions from Jack's perspectives
perspective it is after all virtually
impossible to win in any comparison with
a martyr
death is a tough act to follow I am now
jack told billing is not long after
Joe's death shouta boxing and a match
the shadow is always going to win as he
contemplated a run for Congress in 1946
Jack said he felt terribly exposed and
vulnerable without Joe there to serve as
the focus of his father's ambitions
without Joe on sight to be pushed into
the political arena while Jack bided his
time and considered his options in other
moods however he clearly relished the
idea of a campaign he had after all
spoken frequently in the past about the
prospect of a political career and the
Ambassador himself had told John
Bulkeley as early as 1942 that he
thought Jack had the stuff to be
President so we know that the idea of
Jack and politics was not a new one born
of Joe's death although it may well have
been honed and sharpened by the fallout
from the explosion over the British
Coast in 1944 when Jack ran for Congress
in Boston's 11th district during the
fall of 1946 he did so just as his
father his own good political instincts
and the truth of his personal experience
would have him do as a hero home from
the wars men who pushed back the Japs
read one press release Island by Island
in the Pacific men who stormed the
blazing Normandy on d-day and who
hammered their way across France and
Germany to blunt the Nazi military might
are now
fighting a different kind of campaign a
political battle on behalf of a young
man who at one time during the war was
reported missing in action one of the
impressive features of his campaign has
been the manner in which veterans of all
branches have rallied behind his
candidacy now Jack often worked the
story of pt-109 into his speeches but
did not do so cynically when he spoke of
109 it was always with great and sincere
emotion as on the night he cited the
bravery of Pappy McMahon the eldest and
most severely wounded of his men I felt
Kennedy said in an extemporaneous speech
his courage was the result of his
loyalty to the men around him
most of the courage shown in the war
came from men's understanding of their
interdependence on each other men were
saving each other's lives at the risk of
their own simply because they realized
that perhaps the next day their lives
would be saved in turn and so there was
built up during the war a great feeling
of comradeship and fellowship and
loyalty he reflected that his
comradeship was one of the few aspects
of war that he and other returning
soldiers and sailors missed that sense
of working together for a common cause
in the last days of the campaign Jack's
father arranged for John Hersey's
account of pt-109
already reprinted once in Reader's
Digest to be reprinted yet again in a
pamphlet addition 100,000 copies went
out through the mails along with a press
release signed by Kennedy's old 109 crew
mate William Johnston the Dorchester
truck driver I'm not a politician
Johnston wrote and I don't know much
about politics but if the people of this
district want a congressman with real
abilities and great qualities of
leadership and with unusual courage than
John Fitzgerald Kennedy is their man
somebody in fact Kennedy's opponent has
talked about the need for a seasoned
congressman Kennedy was seasoned enough
to command a PT boat in action he was
seasoned enough for the lives of his
crew to be entrusted to him we may know
we may not know too much about politics
but we know a lot about
John Fitzgerald Kennedy oh that's just a
brief taste of the book itself I enjoyed
writing the book I hope you'll enjoy
reading it
thanks very much can i address any
questions or room I spent a lot of time
at the JFK Library going through papers
there I also spent a lot of time going
through the papers correspondence etc of
colleagues of Joe jr. Kathleen Kennedy
Jack Kennedy and also Joseph Kennedy
senior the Cordell Hull papers of the
Library of Congress for example have a
lot of the diplomatic exchange at
diplomatic pouch exchanges between
ambassador kennedy and the roosevelt
administration back in washington which
makes for very interesting reading and
other papers of various contemporaries
the henry morgenthau jr. papers up at
the franklin roosevelt library at hyde
park
i also talked to to various people who
who it was a few survivors still Zinser
though the last george's ends of a last
surviving four member of the pt-109 only
died last summer
there's still a few people lurking
around who knew these young people when
they themselves were young and that was
a very interesting part of the exercise
but that's the bare bones of how I went
about researching they were neutral
there they they didn't didn't buy me a
car but they didn't try to run my car
off the road and I really didn't need
much of their involvement to be honest
with you the the nature of the book
I was trying to ride it we it was much
more important that I talk to fellow
veterans of the Solomon campaign than to
Ted Kennedy who was six years old seven
years old when a lot of the stuff was
going on but but I had access to what I
needed at the JFK Library and it's my
hope that the family will like the book
one reviewer recently said that it read
as though it was to be the the one of
the first books and what he called us
the second wave of Kennedy revisionism
the the first wave of Kennedy
revisionism having been the intensely
negative biographies that that
culminated in the the dark side of
Camelot a couple of years ago and with
the the new wave of Kennedy revisionism
being a more moderate balanced even
approach that is neither character
assassination nor hagiography
something in the middle something
hopefully resembling truth he did had
not been pushed into the political arena
where everybody seems I think his father
would have done that as the lead son
mm-hmm that John Kennedy had had Joe
lives at John might have done something
different with his life and had some
different orientation other than him my
suspicion my suspicion is that Jack
Kennedy would have wound up in the
political limelight anyway because my
read on Joe Kennedy jr. is that he just
didn't have he wasn't a smartest jack he
didn't have the personality that Jack
had he didn't have so many of Jack's
qualities that made Jack a success as a
politician Joe jr. was disliked by many
people I talked to fellows now quite old
who are at Choate and
Harvard with with Joe jr. and the phrase
bully came up quite a lot he also was
not a fast study which is not certainly
not a moral shortcoming but but he
wasn't as quick as jack to catch on to
things so I think Jack was probably the
more apt pupil and the more guy more
likely to persevere and succeed in
actuality now whether that was the view
within the family families look at their
members with different lenses I have
believed that in the family Joe Jr was
indeed viewed as the heir apparent the
the prince the the next generation and
waiting but I think realistically
speaking Jack was always the more likely
candidate Jack Jack excelled didn't even
try to really and constantly excelled
over Joe Joe Joe jr. Trump went to Spain
and wandered around during the Spanish
Civil War and came back and tried to
write a book about the Spanish Civil War
and it didn't come together and he
couldn't make it happen
and Jack threw together a thesis and
honors thesis at Harvard and wound up
getting it published as became why
England slept and it was a massive bath
bestseller and was a noted author at a
very young age and we as I discussed in
my talk
Jack had all this publicity out of the
Pacific Theater and Joe jr. wasn't
getting much done through no fault of
his own and Jack advanced in rank faster
than Joe did and just add on every level
and Jack wasn't trying to one-up his
older brother but he but he constantly
did without trying which I think says
something Joe I thought his father was
deliberately grooming him to become a
candidate for president before that I
wondered a detail you twice mentioned
the b54 Liberator did you mean that it's
a b-24 Liberator I did I say 50 or if I
meant 20 40 I thought maybe there's
specially-modified
doesn't it seem curious to me that
Elliot first of all Roosevelt Franklin
Roosevelt hated I think Joe Kennedy oh
they did not get along okay maybe the
sons were reflecting that - it seems
curious to me that Elliott Roosevelt is
in a plane right nearby Joe Kennedy
blows up and all it took was pushing the
wrong button at the wrong time to make
that thing blow up and people didn't
like Joe Kennedy I mean is this reading
too much I think it's reading too much
because Elliott didn't have the button
in his plane no Joe I mean is it not I
mean you don't think that kind of thing
happens what's it called in the military
fragging or something I don't like
yeah but III I'm quite sure it didn't
there was that this was not the case but
is it true that Joe senior yeah was
grooming within the family he was
definitely viewed as the the guy who was
gonna be the first Catholic president so
the elimination of that first Joe junior
as a candidate would have been probably
attractive to Franklin Roosevelt but I
don't think Franklin Roosevelt was dumb
enough to think Joseph Kennedy jr. was
really a threat not the only Joseph
Kennedy senior thought Joe jr. had
presidential prospects Oh Elliott no I
want no I don't think I mean I don't
know what Elliott's ambitions were at
that point but he was just he was in air
reconnaissance Elliott Roosevelt and so
they just needed a guy a reconnaissance
guy because since this was a test
mission they wanted to film it to see
how the test one to document it and he
just was available so he just got
assigned to to film it but as I said he
his aircraft that he was in the mosquito
was very severely damaged and he just
barely got back to the base before his
plane really fell apart on him
so I don't think he was complicit first
Navy reaction to pt-109 incident well
it's the positive and negative initially
it depended who was who was viewing who
was talking MacArthur said that Jack
should have been court-martialed for the
pt-109 incident that he had been asleep
at the switch and you know he he wasn't
really doing his job when that several a
number of the crew were asleep Jack may
have been asleep we're not sure
and the Japanese battleship was on them
very quickly no I think it's a
battleship the immediate yeah
and Barney Barney Ross who was a friend
of Jack's who was actually assigned to a
different PT boat but had gone out that
night with pt-109
had been assigned to be the forward
lookout on the on the on the 109 but he
he suffered from night blindness so this
was not a good combination and also
pt-109 was one of the older class of PT
boats that did not have radar there was
no radar on pt-109
so they couldn't see it coming that way
so they should have been extra alert
also Jack had only one of his engines in
gear which was a violation of
regulations and inhibited his ability
once he knew that the ship was on them
it inhibited his ability to get out of
the way so all told the fact that the
disaster happened what did not reflect
well on well it's Jack on Jack as a
commander what did subsequently reflect
well on Jack as a commander was how he
marshaled his men and helped keep him
alive for a week and call it Kennedy
luck I guess that the once they had all
been saved when the Navy official Navy
investigator showed up
to write the investigate and write the
official report for the Navy on what hat
about what a defense fired it turned out
to be Byron white who Jack had partied
with all through Europe two years before
and there have we're great pals and boon
companions and great chums
Byron Whizzer white who just died two
weeks ago yes Kennedy appointed him to
the Supreme Court and before that Byron
worked for for Bobby and Justice
Department and you know of course a
legendary character the Whizzer white
from Colorado State football Fame who
won the Cotton Bowl and and went on to
become the depressions highest-paid
professional football player for
Pittsburgh and then astonished everybody
when he quit that job after just one
year to take a road scholarship and
that's when he met Jack and they spent a
good fair amount of time driving around
Germany and having some fairly
interesting adventures in Germany that I
recount in the in Nazi Germany that I
recount in the book and then if then at
byron white who shows up to write the
report on pt-109
so it's I wouldn't say it's a gloss but
about it but it's certainly an example
of one friend taking the time to not
screw another friend
that's for three to four years three to
four years overall I had the idea
shortly after finishing the lion's pride
that I should take that concept to
another war and another notable
political family and began the research
about two and a half three years of
research and about a year of solid
writing to get it out it's but it's been
four years since might have since the
lion's pride since my last book so
I guess that's it's quite enough for me
I'm ready to move on to something else
what what I have no idea I'm sorry yeah
Oh
later on he got it covered up
politically well you didn't cover it up
he didn't have anything to cover up
although he was sick he wasn't diagnosed
until 1947 so after 1947 certainly he
was covering covering it up and I've
seen I mean I'm not a physician but I've
seen reports where doctors have said
that had Jack Kennedy not died in Dallas
in 63 and been reelected in 64 he would
not have completed his term his second
term you know that he would have died he
thinks so Gary what does happen is
people get older they're more
susceptible and when minor illnesses can
affect people that don't have adequate
reserve and that's where they're at
higher risk for the kinds of things that
most people have the immune system to
compare oh I see
so maybe you would have finished a
second term into any evidence that he
was treated in Cambridge treated in
Cambridge there was a there was a Bruce
medical clinic next to City Hall I know
the son of that doctor who tells him
that Kennedy used to go there for secret
treatments from 1947 on and he would
come there it's sort of sort of out of
the sphere I kind of cut off at 1946 and
you know actually 1945 really I'm really
focusing on the war but I guess he went
for treatment somewhere and cuz it was
around here often enough so that would
make sense
anything else
yeah quarters st. James
it was political payback big time
actually but but they were there's a big
asterisk on that Joe Kennedy had had
latched his star to Franklin Roosevelt
early on he made massive contributions
to the campaigns of 1932 and 1936 like
contributions that in today's dollars
would be the equivalent of about 6
million bucks and FDR at first rewarded
Joe Joe wanted political appointment he
saw that as a pathway to social
acceptance that had thus far evaded him
and FDR first made Joe head of the
Securities and Exchange Commission and
the famous famous explanation of
explanation the morgenthau about that
appointment send a thief to catch a
thief and subsequently Kennedy made
something of a power play within the
Roosevelt administration trying to get
Henry Morgenthau juniors job as
Secretary of the Treasury I was just
talking about this at lunch today I was
eating lunch with Henry Morgenthau the
third and we were talking about this and
Morgenthau juniors successfully rebuffed
Kennedy's play for power and Kennedy
found himself exiled to the to running
the real boring agency the Federal
Maritime Commission and didn't care for
that too much and when Robert worth
Bingham in 1937 the the current
ambassador to the court of st. James is
a Kentucky newspaper publisher Robert
worth Bingham became ill Joe Kennedy saw
this as an opportunity to get the type
of position that would really give him
the social status he had always striven
for
the ambassador to the court of st. James
has automatically made a member of all
sorts of establishments in the UK the
Royal Thames Yacht Club and so on that
the best of brahmins society in new
england often usually aspires to in vain
and franklin roosevelt said to his to
his son james that it was just like joe
kennedy to want to deal with the people
in New England who snubbed him by
becoming a peer of those who they
considered their betters it was
quintessential and and and there's ample
evidence that he really saw the the
position early on as the appeal of the
position to be what it would bring him
socially he told one of his assistants
when they were getting ready to go over
to London he said said to this fellow he
said don't pack too much we're only
staying for six months long enough to
get the family into the Social Register
then we're gonna come home and go to
Hollywood and make some movies and make
some money so I think that says it all
but he wound up staying over there
almost for three years because Franklin
Roosevelt didn't want him back here
you know Gideon Welles hundred years
earlier had said to someone I think
Henry Adams that there are some who are
sent abroad because they're highly
respected and and they can conduct the
business of the United States and a good
and grand way and there are others who
are sent abroad because just to get them
abroad and Joe Kennedy was lalana
roosevelt trying this is before
churchill oh no no i don't i don't think
so
I suppose it did although they were too
polite to say so
and he was grandly treated over there by
all the Brits at first you know now when
he started escorting Charles Lindbergh
around to hell and introducing him to
British audiences to give his defeatist
speeches on yeah for all of 38 when he
started to do things like that and
started to give interviews saying that
Germany was undefeatable and represented
the wave of the future and Britain
oughta just roll over and forget about
Czechoslovakia and all these oh and when
when when Kennedy was hanging out with
the the Clifden set with Nancy Astor and
Waldorf Astor and and the editors
Geoffrey door dog the editors of The
Times the Aster own paper and all of
these other appeasers and and sort of
pro pro-nazi
types in the UK then you know his stock
went down with the British quite a bit
and in time his stock also went down at
home quite a bit but initially he was
treated very grandly and received very
fondly and they got terrific press of
this adorable family large Catholic
family that had come you know it's alive
enough the American Embassy so initially
they they were quite well received
anything else well thank you thanks for
coming
Edouard Rena Hanna's author of the
lion's pride the secret six and his
latest the kennedys at war 1937 to 1945
its published by doubleday visit
Doubleday calm for more information